[Music]
oh yeah i can't always nail this give me
a second
welcome to the quarter cat first take
for sure
first take first try
[Music]
wow we hazed one of our employees
on video cameras oh my god
okay welcome to the corner cast
where we bring it hot uh okay
so um what happened last week guys
we raised a bunch of money for charity
yeah with the help of people we raised
over half a million dollars for charity
which is just
sorry just yeah can we that deserves
like a little clap
yeah there it is that was the little
clapper that's it that's it
that's all you got that was pretty
special that's insane that was pretty
nuts
yeah sam and i were at our friend's uh
bachelor party
and and like you know we're checking our
phones once in a while and then as it
got to the end of that auction it's just
like sorry guys we're gonna be on our
phones for half an hour here
just constantly refreshing the page
yeah like come to the party it's like
yeah sorry i can't
gotta watch this it's hard to take your
eyes off two once-in-a-lifetime moments
going on right there
friends bachelor party raising yeah 500
500 grand for charity 600 now wow the
price of ethereum going up
which is funny because like you know so
we did the nft auction
and you know i want to give a shout out
to the
people that bid on the the items and the
people that bought them because
they're the ones who are you know
putting the cash in uh for this charity
but
you know so we do this and it's not like
you just get money in your bank account
you end up with these crypto dollars
so then jake's been trying to figure out
that process
dude welcome to the world of
cryptocurrency jake like rude and
awakening here
dude you wouldn't believe man i had to
take a crash course in it over the last
four weeks because
you know i i i've been following it
you know like because i just follow the
financial markets and the economic
the economics but i i wasn't like
into the intricacies of how you
buy it and like how you exchange it and
how like all these
wallet systems and the codes and then
your passphrase and like all this other
stuff that's
involved with it oh yeah and uh
it was very overwhelming for a few days
um well i was trying to saturate as much
knowledge as possible and now i feel
like i'm
i've i've gotten past the first
educational phase and now
um now it's but now it's figuring out
like okay
um you know convert it off
and then now now no pressure here's the
other thing
you can't you you wouldn't believe how
hard
the tax system makes it to give money
away to people
you wouldn't believe it it's it's if i
you wouldn't believe it i told you you'd
think
oh you want to give away money to people
okay so here's
here's a hundred dollars i give away a
hundred dollars and then i write it i
check a box on my tax return that says i
gave a hundred dollars to so and so
easy done right i don't get taxed on the
hundred dollars because it's
some money i gave away oh hold on
let me stop you right there there's a
whole bunch of things that can happen
because people be because people abuse
the charitable donations thing
unfortunately non-profits abuse it
charities abuse it people abuse it
people create charities for themselves
and then like
donate money to themselves and this is a
little messy sorry yeah
sorry there's a little little bit of
politics you'll ever get in the podcast
oh i'm just saying i'm just saying like
that's why it's hard
yeah yeah yeah so because because when
they see because when the irs sees like
a donation and they see
okay well you you donated 500 000
to a charity okay we're gonna need to
know that that was legit
because you know so anyways
it's uh it's interesting because you not
only have to learn the currency
crypto side you have to learn the tax
side and then
make sure that they don't get in each
other's way
and then everything with with taxing as
it
falls into the crypto world if you're
like buying selling that's a whole other
thing capital gains
yeah it's it's definitely an
accountant's worst nightmare
yeah like how you you know some people
bid on these pieces with crypto
with ethereum and then it's like oh but
then the ethereum goes up in value
and what was originally like 580
thousand dollars is now 620 thousand
dollars
like that's like what are the gains
taxed or how does that work you know
it gets it gets real funky i mean that's
that's why i
just have questions about using
cryptocurrency for actual
mercantile in general like how how are
you gonna
do that i mean arguably you're outside
the tax system if you stay in crypto the
whole time
that's true very true but also like i
could pay you
a bitcoin for a piece of bread and then
you know that it's
doubled in value by the end of the day
and you're like right and the the
volatility is is pretty extreme
yeah this is crazy um but it has yeah i
mean to its
credit it has we had you had this big
spike in february
march but yeah and
before that it was relatively stable and
by relatively
nico we were talking about this earlier
like fluctuating like fifteen to twenty
percent
dude the only stable thing in crypto is
the volatility
i'm serious really i mean if you look at
the pattern it's like you get all these
huge hits then these corrections and
then
very consistently another huge hit and
then very consistently another
correction
so yeah it makes me wonder if
billionaires
are like controlling a lot of the market
hell yes they are
oh definitely yeah no
they're playing us all for sure like
yeah because if you own enough
to like like elon musk or whatever
people are saying he
you know controls it with his tweets or
whatever like
all he has is tweet bitcoin yeah like
the price
shoots up 10k yeah so yes
is the answer to that i think that's a
fair speculation
well you think about it and it's if it
exists obviously outside of any
any market yes um and so because of that
it's it has advantages but it also has
disadvantages in the sense of like there
it is
completely unregulated meaning anybody
can
come in and do anything with it
and you know the only thing they can't
do
is lie about how much they
have or don't have because it's actually
on the blockchain
true what's that yeah it's really crazy
but
it is nice to see it stabilizing a
little bit um
you know but uh who knows um
who knows where that that ship will sail
it's uh
time will tell man i mean the ship
hasn't sailed
away yet so it's still here with us
we're still sailing it you know
yeah there's definitely drug money
laundering implications
in that industry um to a degree that
i don't even think i want to understand
but yeah you know if we can take a
little bit of it and do a little good
with it i'm on board with that
yeah i mean it's not every day you get
to raise that much for
a good cause so that was pretty cool
seeing it
we were all guessing i think in the last
podcast we were throwing around some
guesses but we were like
if it gets past 100k that's gonna be
crazy
yeah that kind of was like our our
benchmark for success
is if it could hit that collectively
with all the six pieces
that would be a success for us and
obviously it did
six times that that's awesome which is
now we step into the second realm which
is
how do you actually give that money to a
charity you know i mean
obviously you can just like call them up
yeah here's a check well i guess i'm
assuming you call them up like
hi i have lots of money for you
you need to so you need to be you need
to be
careful because it uh
if you don't do the taxes the right way
then you can also get
taxed on it and get audited because of
it
you can it's yeah
so is this going to be like an ongoing
process over the next couple weeks for
you guys
of like figuring out how to funnel this
crazy amount of crypto
and the cash and then yeah cash cause
that's the other thing it's not like to
the check
just guaranteed like like for you to
turn your crypto into dollars somebody
needs to buy the crypto
it's not like there's just an agency
that's like yeah and i'll guarantee this
dollar about like
you know you can't just instantly turn
into dollars someone else needs to give
you those dollars
for the the coinage whatever it's called
well coinbase will probably do that
right but it's still it's working
through the system of you know it's like
stocks
yeah you know right you're not like
that's a lot of things people don't know
about stocks is you think like
when you have a stock and then you sell
it
you're just you're just selling it back
to like the company
or whoever but what you have to do is
you have to put the stock out there and
you have to say
i am holding these stocks out at this
price
and you have to wait for a buyer to come
along and say i will buy those at that
price
yeah it doesn't necessarily happen
instantly right
dude can you imagine like working in the
stock market back in the day when it was
all paper and yeah to actually be there
with like your like kind of
ticker tape or whatever it was like
i got 7 45 7 45 7 45
you're like punching people to get your
stock sold like
there's some crazy photos of the stock
exchange back in the day that are like
pretty wild man yeah pretty wild
um so you know the the main
charity that we were going to that we're
donating to is uh direct relief
um yeah they're rated really highly
they're very common focus because
this is a thing like you know looking at
like just you know culture
american culture and worldwide culture
for a minute here but you know obviously
a little more focused on american
culture
like we haven't i think it's just kind
of how human beings operate a little bit
but we have i feel like we haven't
really as a culture or society
stopped to like pay tribute
to the thousands of people that passed
away from covent 19.
cause we're still kind of just like ah
blinders on just power through which you
kind of have to do a little bit to like
get to the other side of it you know
like
when you're in when you're in the [ __ ]
you gotta put your head down and push
through and
you know i think the president finally
did that right he's finally like
acknowledged it
which is a start like just saying like
this is bad like
yeah you know like that's a thing that
like starts as a society
we need to have that moment we need to
like collectively be like hey
let's like like we build for memorials
for you know people that die in
accidents or you know terrorist attacks
or anything else like that like
we we need to do that we need to
acknowledge like
the pain in the suffering that people
have
been through here which we haven't
really done yet you know people talk
about it here and there but there's not
really like
it's not really like a social feeling
for it yet um
and so like that's part of what inspired
us wanting to do this charity was to
start with that process of like hey
let's acknowledge the fact that half a
million people died
and let's acknowledge that this like is
sad and this is a thing that a lot of
people are suffering from and have had
to deal with
um how can we help how can we start you
know taking that next step
so you know unfortunately that's
politicized now though unfortunately it
is but you know acknowledging
tragedy is now politicized in this
country we should
we all should we should all acknowledge
the people that we should also
acknowledge the fact that
a lot of companies stepped up and made a
vaccine in less than a year which is
that's like the heroic achievement in a
zombie film and everything's like
yeah i don't want it yet it smells like
definitely
that that is super far under
rated yeah i think like
we we that that is the that is
like all the things working correctly
yeah in in that in that sense you know
and i understand there's
you know different opinions of out there
and i think each individual should
decide like
you know how and when they want it but
that aside
you just set that aside for a second and
you think okay when
when nature put a gun to our head
everyone was able to play together
maybe we should take a little bit more
of that and remember that
and stop fighting as much about things
that don't matter yeah
definitely um yeah that was i think
like technologically uh you know you
have
you have the best of you have the best
parts of capitalism working with the
best
parts of government um you know you have
technology playing this huge role
like all of those things have their
pitfalls
but in this case they were all able to
work together to actually come up with
something good
yeah and that's that's pretty remarkable
[Music]
hey guys welcome back to this section of
the brandio daniel cast where i tell you
about today's sponsor story blocks now
if you don't know
storybox is the one-stop shop for all of
your stock asset needs they have a
virtually
unlimited library of high quality
royalty-free assets whether that's a
b-roll clip a template or a motion
graphic or some music or a sound effect
they've got it and with an unlimited all
access plan you can
download as much as you want whenever
you want for whatever purposes
i say this all the time but i'm saying
again commercial what else what else
guys
youtube videos monetized or not doesn't
matter because it's all
royalty free anyways
we use them all the time over here at
quarter digital and that's
one of the things that makes
post-production easy for us
if you're part of a creative team or
you're a creator yourself talk to your
team leader about getting an
enterprise plan head on over to
storyblocks.comcast to get started
that's
storyblocks.com corridorcast to get
started and um
well you'll get all the things that i
just mentioned anyways let's get back to
it okay
so when we were doing this charity you
know direct relief is gonna be the main
beneficiary
but there's like initially we're gonna
say like okay hundred percent is going
to direct relief but then we realize
like we have no idea how much money this
charity is gonna actually bring in you
know if it brings in like sixty thousand
eighty thousand you know whatever then
i'll go to direct relief but what if it
brings in
five hundred thousand it's like well
yeah maybe we should step back for a
second and like set aside one hundred
thousand of that
to put to like another charity that's
focused on another aspect of covet 19.
yeah you also have to be careful about
the ones you pick because uh not all of
them are
there's a certain like tiers of
aggradation that the tax code actually
takes takes with with it
so um i'm glad you picked direct relief
because unfortunately they
have like this this high tier tax
value um but if you don't have that
if you pick one that's that's not at
that level then
you can open yourself up to different
taxation on it as well
um so dude that's fascinating it's kind
of a cool topic for a video
like everyone you know no one really
knows like how do you actually
donate a large amount of money to
charity like because there's all these
stories of also like these like
charities that are like crooked and like
you know it's being funneled into the
wrong places
and like how do you how do you even like
safeguard against that
yeah because when you're starting this i
asked jordan to do some research and
direct relief popped up as being so
basically being like one of the top
charities in the nation
like 100 of the money goes to direct
relief
um that's where the name comes from um
because you have indirect
you know help too but director's like
i'm going to give you money and i'm
going to give you items that i bought
with the money like that's direct i'm
just going to give it to you
um and direct relief is an organization
that deals with medical stuff
uh you know not just cover 19. like
right now it's 100 percent covered 19
focus but
you know they're they're medical focused
like if you know there's an earthquake
they'll bring in doctors and clinics and
you know
they'll do all that kind of stuff um you
know donate all the safety equipment
health equipment and so on and so forth
um but you know now that we raise so
much money what i'm thinking is
you know i kind of want to break it down
from like the national level which is
direct relief and like
do the bulk of the money to that and
then like kind of start and like do like
a kind of a tiered thing that goes a
little bit more local
i mean dude we have one of the we have
like what
the state's biggest homeless population
like right in our neighborhood here
that's the other aspect of thinking of
is uh so you know it's been on the news
in la
right now in that they shut down a big
homeless encampment in echo park
you know and people are arguing on all
sides of it uh but one of the things is
you know
uh a group that went in and worked
really hard to try to get
at least you know share the resources
being like hey here's rooms that are
available here's shelters you can go to
with the homeless
uh was sila s-e-l-a-h i think
um you know they're they're known for
going there and just boots on the ground
being like hey i'm gonna walk to each
tent talk to each person and be like
here's where you can go here's what we
can do
um so i'm kind of feeling like you know
i need to do a little more research on
this to like really round it out but
you know direct relief will be the main
beneficiary and maybe something that's
like at a state level and then something
that's local
and c-law is one of the things that i'm
thinking about for
the local so what exactly would be the
idea there
um i mean it'd just be a donation to
them to because they're
working hard to try to deal with the
homeless issue
um which i guess is tangential it's it's
related to the kova 19 issue because
these part like these homeless
encampments popped up in the parks
because of the whole pandemic to begin
with
yes um making it worse for sure yeah and
they're trying to you know trying to get
people off the street trying to get them
vaccinated
uh trying to keep kova 19 from ravaging
the homeless population as well
um it's sad man it's like especially in
my neighborhood in koreatown right now
it is way worse than i've ever seen it
yeah and
people need help yeah dude well really
let's help
medical supplies charity money you know
so that's what we're working through
uh yeah at least that's what i'm working
through on this um i'm excited to do it
like it's really
it's really something i'm looking
forward to like dealing with
yeah yeah the fun the fundamental the
fundamentals there
are opportunities yeah you know
that's that's what it comes down to
so if we can find a place to put it
where we can in some way
in some small way foster opportunities
for people
that's gonna do the most you know
yeah definitely um we should talk a
little bit about
you know so we made a video that
you know kicked off this charity and uh
yeah we did yeah it was a very uh
yeah controversial polarizing as
i said and you know honestly i was i was
sad to see the way people reacted i get
i get why they did
but you know without going too deep into
what people should and shouldn't think i
think it's important that we talk a
little bit about how we make these
videos
um because we when we put out videos in
the corridor crew
you know it's it's a heightened reality
like we all know we are on camera
and we are playing it up for camera
because you know in real life
like i don't emote a lot yeah
none of us do we're regular people like
everybody else you're kind of just chill
do your thing i remember i had such a
real awakening with youtubers dude like
youtube like
i think the first like youtuber i met in
real life was olin rogers oh yeah and
like
i love the guy he's like super animated
on camera but like
when you meet him in person he's so
soft-spoken like you know
yeah very thoughtful very just like
quiet to himself
like um super cool dude but like
totally different than his on-camera
persona yeah i mean that's that's the
thing you know
videos are storytelling so you are
making a point
of putting yourself out there and
communicating like you know you have an
emotion
and you're going to communicate that
emotion in a way that's very clear so
you're going to heighten it you know and
it's like it's still coming from a
a seed of truthfulness like it all is um
but there's definitely an aspect like
improv theater and so
you know i like to think that we are
basically the irl version of the office
um we have a bit of that vibe going on
which i love i think it's
awesome and entertaining and hilarious
um
but i think it's easy to feel like the
story you're getting is a hundred
percent
like that's exactly what happened and
the emotions that i'm feeling from the
story is the emotions that they must be
feeling in that moment and it's like
well i just want to remind everybody
like we're not we're not the kind of
youtube channel that
goes out there and like films their
friends having a shitty moment and then
putting it up there for everybody to see
like that's not what we do
intentionally intentionally yeah i mean
yeah we intentionally don't do that
um sorry yeah it's not gonna be about
what we've said
yeah that's like that keeps carmichael
on top of the burj khalifa in which case
all bets are off
i mean that's like those are the when we
were exploring that stuff with you know
nick and carmichael back in the day like
that's when we kind of learned that it's
like
too many channels on youtube like go out
there and like make somebody suffer or
take advantage of somebody or exploit
people
and like we don't do that explicitly
like we hate that
um we've had our learning curves though
like we were pranking rent for a long
time and
you know we had we had to stop that
because it was like straight up
turning from pranks to like actual like
hazing and
we realized like okay okay let's look at
this from an outside perspective
yeah we freaking yeah i mean well you
guys know which one i'm talking about
the troutons will know um i still feel
bad for that
um we had to reassess we had to reassess
so it's good you do that but
no like you're saying it's not like we
were like oh pier's having a horrible
time let's like point the camera at him
in people and like tell people to like
say
screw you peter no i
the video could have been cut in a way
where you guys were more in on the joke
and that is i think came down to our
like the editing process
and myself and dean
deciding like and assuming that you guys
would be a little bit more in on or i
guess
in on the joke like and you know like
being able to take like take
yeah with a great assault when you're
like you have a heel in wrestling and
like
a bad guy
when you kind of step up in the boss
role you know into the videos
which is like realistic but it's also
we're heightening it for a video
it's not like people come out and like
you know you know like jake is hazing
people
about the swoosh brethren video is that
i got there was a lot of comments of
people like
ripping into me for being being the heel
and um no one said a word
everyone was just and then peter it's
like oh peter
hater peter
well i mean you were the people in that
video jake was
the people in that video it was funny um
i knew that people would react that way
and yeah i
we we shot the video like with that in
mind like i'll be the bad guy
i'll be the guy who's playing it up and
like
making it hard on everybody and not
having fun because
that's if you if you like distill my
character
that is like what my approach to smash
brothers is
but like i'm not like this
you know in real life um
i mean let's be real jake there's some
truth there a lot of truth in that video
right i mean we always start with the
truth and then we decide how to put it
into a narrative
that's yeah it but it's not like yeah
exactly we do start with the truth and
the truth is like i do think
it's kind of a waste of time but you
guys feel like it's very good for
camaraderie that's the truth
um and so so you deal with that
right yeah i'm not gonna like get mad
about it i just
and happened to ask peter to make a game
that he's actually finishing up right
now for the website of the website yeah
yeah actually we haven't announced that
publicly oops
that's why we encourage you that's why
we encourage you to listen to the
podcast because
uh we are loose lips over here
smush brethren available for download
and play
uh as soon as the website phase two goes
live which is still planned
for wednesday april 7th that's next week
now it won't be massive multiplayer
online
so forgive us you know we're going to
have to build up to that point
but if enough people download it and
play it um
that is something we want to do is like
expand on it
and and continue to build out buildings
new attacks and moves
for each character yeah yeah totally
have dobby and steve the landlord in
there and brett son
dude you could you could like a little
special yeah
he comes out of the dlc he comes out
with a gravity bomb
and like just like just like creates a
cloud
that's just special remember when we
were like doing that video where we got
the huge inflatable balls
and ran over carmichael or hit him with
my car yeah steve comes in he's like
damn you could smoke a lot of pot out of
that thing i'm like wow
dude oh steve dude what a national
treasure man
we gotta he needs to come by soon but
back to people i guess
uh yeah i guess you know at least on
this podcast you guys actually hear like
the
this is us just being 100 real on this
podcast um
in the quarter crew videos you know
you're seeing hours of not days
boiled down into something like just go
back to the render challenge for example
you know that
that was a two-hour thing and it's like
in one way it was only two hours you
know it's us sitting down to make it run
over two hours and
something doesn't work out whatever you
know it's like it was two hours
um but at the same time like keep in
mind that the majority of
what was happening in real life there is
us sitting at our computers working
we get up we talk some trash we joke we
laugh
we sit back down and keep working um
like to be fair i'm just gonna put this
out there
i don't want to like be saying peter
wasn't having a bad time because
he definitely wasn't having a great time
i think he'd never met mike before
so he didn't really know what a unique
flower he is
and we all kind of know and like
actually
mike off camera when like we're not all
like when he's not feeding off of our
like
extremely hype youtube energy yeah he's
like much more mellow and like very
actually
he's pretty nice he's not like he came
across in that video mike is a super
nice guy but
peter definitely wasn't prepared for
that and
i think when when we saw that
we were already so far into the video
that it was just like
let's keep going and also he's wearing
the mask the whole time so i couldn't
like see his facial expressions
but i did see at one point he was just
like rolling his eyes
and it was like are you all right and he
just didn't answer me and i'm like okay
i'm just not gonna
i'm not gonna do anything hopefully it's
all fine and
i think that video could have really
benefited from keeping in
like dean dean was saying the other day
he's like
there are a couple moments where like i
had peter and people and
everyone like me behind the camera
laughing at like things that he would do
like when people accidentally and it was
a real accident dropped clint's toy
right we were all left we were cracking
up for like five minutes
everybody clint was like the one
laughing most because it was so
perfectly timed yeah like and it
shattered in the most expressive way
like
every little piece went to the four
corners of the studio yeah it's also
like exactly what happens in the game
too when you carry too many items
so like but because that's my special
edition yeah sam porter bridges dude so
like we're always trying to find
a story line uh hey you can check this
out in functional filmmaking coming out
in a couple months
on my episode but we're always trying to
find coming out next week
next week but we're always trying to put
a
story line into something so for this
video we
realized that so okay
let's take it back so we filmed with
people over the course of well two days
but
the first day we were filming this
render challenge and then we also sat
down
and did this q a video and the original
plan was that we were gonna
integrate the two videos into one big
video like a big
chunky nft crypto art thing
we didn't know that people would then go
on to sell his uber mega christie's
auction
art piece and become like a household
name overnight
so when that happened and the video had
already been pushed for other reasons
like several weeks down the line it was
supposed to come out several weeks
earlier
we decided let's
in order to well honestly like
capitalize on that success and try to
like
help ourselves out it's like why don't
we just not cut down that q a so much
because i think people are actually
legitimately now that he is a household
name interested in everything he has to
say
like i think putting out that raw uncut
version of that q
a that isn't chopped up into the other
video might be better right now because
people are like
who is this guy what's you know what's
on his mind so
we did that and that means that the
render video then with people
was a little bit i don't want to say
sparse but it was lacking that like b
story so when looking through the
footage and seeing what moments there
are
the thing that instantly stood out to
dean and i as the most
funny interesting thing is this dynamic
that comes off a little
bit it came off a little bit more subtle
than it did in the final video between
peter and beeple
where peter was just rolling his eyes
you know peoples being
people and like being super like you
know intense
and competitive and to people
oh sorry yeah and we just decided like
that's probably going to be the best
story to like
focus on and well not to mention there's
the whole aspect of like you know
peter's
an incredibly talented cg artist but
he's also super young and like
you know here he is meeting people and
people doesn't know who he is
and so there's this moment where like
you know you have somebody
like peter who you know i guess
he's a he's also like a hot shot you
know
like he's very good at what he does it's
hot shot and everyone in our audience
knows that so yeah and so to see him in
a situation
where somebody doesn't you know imagine
like brad pitt hangs out with somebody
who doesn't know who brad pitt is
you know like imagine he's like acting
in a student film and none of the people
on that
crew know this this guy's a real like
they're like have you have you
have you heard brad uh read his he's
really good and so it's like it is a
fascinating situation once again just a
reminder this is only a two hour thing
like
so your work doesn't really get used
that much like yeah it's maybe a little
bit annoying in the moment but like
just like peter himself said like the
moment passes and you continue doing
your thing like it's not it
was not that big of a deal um yeah and
it was just
it was also just a fascinating start to
the
to be fair to the audience
when you're watching a video you only
know what's being right
it's true that's very true and so that
is the point
right that that's the that's the point
of of telling a story through the medium
of
a video like you you're only you're only
only what i show you don't look over
there yeah you know
and so like
i i understand like we've done so much
of it now like
and we do have a new uh a huge new
audience that's
only joined us in the last you know
sometimes even months you know within
the last year
um that hasn't seen all that other
earlier stuff that like we consider to
be
ground truth for a lot of these stories
um
i think that's what makes watching
through our library entertaining because
you discover those things like as you
watch through it but
um i also understand you know
first time coming in for the first time
like imagine
you know you stumble across a david
dobrik video you're like
i don't know who any of these people are
like what's what's going on like why is
this
like this what are they doing this for
right i'm just taking it at face value
so i think there was a little bit of
that going on too now
obviously um you know people
well well i think the bottom line is
people love peter really
yeah honestly and like that's awesome
everyone commenting we're not faulting
you guys like
this is our like my bad you know like
i'm taking the fall for this because we
could have presented it in a more
well beneficial way i think yeah but
i i don't know like usually when
everyone here at corridor
is cracking up at something it's a good
sign like
if you watch the old sam and nico videos
when we do our brainstorms on camera
like you can see many corridor videos
that have just
been incepted from like us just in tears
laughing in this room yeah
and as soon as we watch the rough cut
that dean had
of that render challenge and we're
seeing that dynamic we're all cracking
up
so it's like obvious like let's lean
into the storyline and we didn't really
think twice about it so
yeah but yeah i mean the audience
checked us for sure so
you know like another time you gotta
have that freedom though you know to
like
well you know what this this is a good
story and let's roll with it
like and and deal with whatever might
come
when you make three videos a week it's
like you're gonna fail sometimes
i mean it was a good story i mean yeah
we can all see how like how emotionally
engaging
that is very true like all these
comments were inspired because there was
story and there was character
they say good art gets an emotional
response it doesn't have to be a good
positive one if you get a response yeah
but anyway it's it should never be
like peter's expense so you know yeah i
think that's that's a good lesson just
across the board or mike's expense or
anybody's expense really but i will say
like take a deep breath all right
there's no
like i really don't think this is a case
of workplace harassment i saw a lot of
comments
saying like sam and nico need to like
apologize to peter and stuff and like
i mean if peter wants that he's free to
say it but like
it's a little bit intense yeah it's a
little bit intense if our workplace is
in any way replace harassment like
good luck dude i'm only allowed to play
20 minutes of smashing
dude
yeah [ __ ] where's osha i guess
just you know
i want to thank mike aka beeple for
joining us and i want to
point out to everyone that's very
critical of him if you're listening to
this podcast
his presence here like he was already a
pretty big name he already sold a bunch
of pieces for millions of dollars before
he came on our show
he came out here and did this render
with us
to not only help us raise money for
charity to help other people but also to
help us as well and introduce us to
this new world of digital art and to
educate us and to educate everybody else
who was watching the videos
and he reached out to us by the way
right he reached out to us um
to do it and even after his christie's
auction
like he was still helping us get the
stuff set up he's helping us get the
ball rolling
he's he really went out of his way in a
way that i would not expect
anybody at his like fame and notoriety
to do to do so to help us
and also looking at the rest of his
pieces like he is constantly selling
pieces for charity like he basically did
his christie's auction
and he had the one back in the fall that
raised three and a half million dollars
but after the christie's auction he's
basically gone like
i'm gonna give away all my art and he's
just giving it away to people and
letting them resell it
and making money off of it like yeah
he's actively helping and changing the
lives of many many people
um so you know like to that i want to
say thank you you know
thank you people aka mike for helping us
raise all this money for charity thank
you for
helping you know open our eyes a little
bit to this world of nfts and
you know there's a lot of criticism
around the nfts that we've since
you know looked into and wren had a
great uh discussion about that with you
guys in the last podcast if you guys
haven't heard that you should definitely
go listen to it
um but you know it was it was really
selfless of him to come out here and
participate with us and he's
continuously
doing these very selfless you know
charitable things
um i wish more rock stars
would act like he does did he uh did he
see the video
nico i'm certain he saw the video did
anything happen from that i don't know i
don't know that would be speculation i
don't think so
um but either way it's uh
you know i appreciate people watching
out for peter i appreciate people being
emotionally honest with us
um but yeah you know i also want to
basically say thank you to people um
thank you to peter for participating in
that video as well yeah thanks to peter
for being a good sport man
you know we all have to be a good sport
sometimes you know it reminds me of um
the bow video when you guys are holding
a 360 camera on an arrow
yeah um and my my bow got chewed up
and yeah you know like was i happy about
it no of course not
you know i i don't want my bow to be
chewed up
it does have sentimental value but like
you know
was i so torn up and emotionally shook
like
no it's it was an accident you know and
you guys
filmed that reveal and like it wasn't
like
you know i'm like no and like super
angry like
i'm going to express a little bit more
for camera i i mean the moment you guys
walked in the door i knew what was up
right and so there's a reaction
you know the reaction i gave like half
of its truth but half of it is me also
going like okay
in this moment that we're now doing
improv theater in this moment
this is what i need to sell as a
character to make this moment compelling
to make this part of a storyline that
makes sense like is it truthfulness in
it of course there is
but there's also me understanding that
there's a camera in the room five feet
away from me
and so i'm going to acknowledge the
truthfulness but then make sure it's
communicated in the performance as well
um you know and and that's what you see
in that video like
when when i was younger um
i used to believe that
uh that like heightening reality
i used to think that's that's like
wrong because it's not real it's it's
not
real but what you don't realize
or what i didn't realize at least was
that
the the heightened version of
any human story and like the condensed
version of any human story
is is always better than the real thing
like the reason why we have mythology
and the reason why we have like these
common
narratives through different stories
across time
is because those are those are essential
to like
our truths and our human condition and
like our relationships with one another
and our relationships with ourselves and
with the universe
like and it's distilled into these
examples
that people then pass on you know
through storytelling if it's like
nobody wants to know like
the entirety of what happened in the
iliad
who's the main character the iliad hope
that's not homer it was written by
holmes uh odysseus
odysseus it's like odysseus's life was
probably
pretty like rough and boring
you know if he was a real person but
like the interesting parts
are in the iliad yeah yeah you know it's
like that's the other thing to remember
like just to remind everybody because
i think as as time progresses the
technology progresses we forget this
even more and more
like the only perfect medium is being
there
personally when the moment happens
everything from that point is a
facsimile in a representation of what
happened i mean even this podcast
like when watching a video we're trying
to communicate
the depths of the human experience
through some pictures that are playing
at 24 frames per second in an
audio track that plays along with it and
that's all you get yeah
you know so if you're going to try to
tell a story
you have to heighten it a little bit for
those things to read but those that's
that's
how you acknowledge these human truths
and you have these human experiences
you know you need to do that and that's
totally okay to do
but you know that is the process you
have to do to be able to tell stories
in a video medium yeah
yeah yeah so those are stories are
better than the real thing
yeah so for sure uh this podcast is
gonna be slightly shorter than usual
just because i got it to a late start
because we had to take our dubstep guns
two promo pictures on the website
dubstep dude
and cool uh me mike
and sam are gonna be working on uh new
dubstep guns 2 video if it gets ringlets
whoa
um mike diva is coming in from collab
coming in for another collab
um but if the video gets greenlit yeah
if that's the key
um come on but the uh the funny thing is
we haven't started this process yet but
i feel like we could get some like
really legit like electronic artists for
dubstep guns too
because i feel like guns one is like
again legit electronic artist
and we gotta get uh andy sandberg
oh right he's gonna make a cameo
he's like the chief or something yeah
that'd be great
i would it'd be something cool to get
skrillex in for uh
yeah or just even in the video he's the
one
he's the wise old sage in like some
warehouse
corner still making dubstep and you guys
have to go see him to
obtain a secret power yeah i don't know
if he still lives
in downtown l.a but at least a little
while back he literally lived like down
the street
oh i guess people saw him by we're
squished like two months ago so i guess
he still lives here
wait guys that was like over a year and
a half ago
[Laughter]
time flies i think all
of our memories yeah i mean like all my
memories start in 2020
like before then like even 20 nights
yeah it goes to 2019 and begins at 20
21.
it's such a weird blur man it's such a
weird place it's like when your clock
flips from like midnight to like one
o'clock like there's no zero o'clock
what 2019 to 2021 yeah
all right well thanks for listening to
the podcast everybody you know like a
lot of people have been suggesting me to
do some time codes
uh in the description below so people
can kind of see like you know if we're
talking about different subjects what to
jump to
maybe we should try that for this one
yeah
so if you're listening to this and you
want to put in the comments
the time code i will pin it to the top
nice well if you paste it in the
description i believe it actually then
segments
the timeline oh yeah with chapter
markers it has a little like
oh it does yeah a little second yeah
it's fantasy fancy you're right
okay i was just pretending and being
lazy freaking pro youtube tip
i didn't even know that that's crazy
yeah you just put it in the description
it's really nice for tutorials
i love it when tutorials do that yeah
because it's like okay here's the part i
need to know
uh yeah but hey everybody listening
thank you for listening to the podcast
uh thank you for watching our videos um
oh i think it's
it's already almost time to play us out
it is time you know a lot of people were
talking about your blackberry rendition
i actually haven't heard it yet
would you want to play it one more time
encore
ready yeah
[Music]
peter trying to make a render with
people
will he render that head and will it get
in
release the peter cut
[Music]
that's it that's great all right all
right guys
thank you guys for watching all right